il rêvait de devenir footballeur il a
fini député après avoir été journaliste
sportif puis mère mon invité aime
relever toujours de nouveaux défis un
peu à l'image d'un sportif de haut
niveau
[Musique]
bonjour car le livre bonjour Clément
Méric alors il y a une constante chez
vous que ce soit chez le journaliste
sportif ou chez l'homme politique vous
aimez faire le show faire le spectacle
et on va voir que ça remonte à loin
je suis étudiant deuxième année de dogue
en communication communication
j'aime l'imitation ah tiens bonsoir en
1789 Vincent Perrot n'était pas né
pourtant pierre bon fidèle à lui-même
chercher des jeunes à la France car ils
savaient cher téléspectateurs que 200
ans il se rela face à la caméra pour
être agrandir bon je te pile le chef on
échange
très bien alors ça c'était en 1989 sur
FR3 magnifique imitation d'Alain Decaux
on l'a reconnu à l'époque vous étiez
étudiant en communication et des jeux
télé je crois que vous en avez fait une
trentaine c'est ça et vous aviez une
idée bien précise en tête en faisant ça
bah l'idée c'est exactement ce que vous
venez de voir là c'était pas gagné des
machines à laver gagner des séjours des
voyages ou autres c'était finalement
faire un métier public et il se trouve
que à la fin de cette journée-là Michel
pécard qui était un des invités de
l'émission
me propose de devenir pigiste d'une
télévision locale qui allait voir le
jour un mois plus tard qui s'appelait
Evelyne première où j'ai démarré le 18
décembre 1989 forcément c'est le moment
là vous les oubliez pas et je suis venu
directeur de cette télévision locale en
1994 et cette stratégie vous a plutôt
réussi vous l'avez dit ça vous a permis
de mettre un pied dans le milieu de la
télé jusqu'à devenir patron des sports
de Canal+ et ce qui est marrant c'est
que vous n'avez pas changé car l'olive
c'est à dire que l'homme politique que
vous êtes devenu ben il fait pareil par
exemple vous aimez vous filmer pour vous
mettre en scène sur les réseaux sociaux
chaque dimanche avec votre petit footing
qui se termine par un petit message
politique vous postez ça sur Twitter et
puis après chaque adoption de loi aussi
on vous voit vous filmez par exemple ici
dans la cour d'honneur de l'Assemblée
pour dire j'étais là j'ai voté telle loi
alors c'est sympa mais est-ce que vous
en faites pas un peu trop dans le
domaine de la communication
donc j'ai pu avoir avec avec mes parents
ma petite maman avait perdu les siens à
3 ans et 5 ans on était 8 dans la
famille quand vous êtes 8 dans la
famille vous êtes toujours à la première
personne du pluriel jamais à la première
personne du singulier quand vous êtes 8
autour d'une table qui est presque une
table de ferme puisque ma petite maman
était d'origine fermière que votre papa
a fait 42 ans c'est chez Simca Chrysler
vous savez ce que c'est que la mobilité
sociale verticale vous savez ce que
c'est que la mixité sociale et ça j'aime
beaucoup et il faut surtout pas que ça
change parce que parce que sinon on
perdrait quelque chose on perdrait son
âme alors ce dont il faisait aussi
permis de vous faire beaucoup d'amis et
souvent des amis très bien placés là
aussi dans tous les milieux dans le
milieu de la télé des patrons de chaîne
ou des personnalités comme Michel
Denisot par exemple dans le milieu du
sport plein de stars de foot du rugby du
judo avec David Douillet aussi qui a été
qui a joué un rôle important dans votre
carrière politique au tout début des
grands patrons aussi Henri Lachmann ou
Claude bbéart vous êtes un homme de
réseau on peut le dire alors parfois on
donne une connotation négative à ça mais
vous l'as de réseau j'assume le fait
d'être celui que vous avez indiqué c'est
à dire que je d'être finalement sans
contrôle sans a priori sans état d'âme
je dis souvent on voit que le Bébert à
l'écran j'ai souvent que les plus grands
sont les plus simples mais c'est la
vérité il y a pas de
Clément mairie ça fait quelques années
aussi on travaille pas de secret que que
nous nous connaissons je pense c'est
croisé
vous étiez au patron des sports
exactement voilà moi j'ai un profond
respect pour toutes celles et ceux que
je croise j'adore par exemple le matin
une à deux fois par semaine prendre mon
petit café que les les éboueurs qui
passent devant chez moi voilà j'ai
autant de plaisir à faire cela sans
aucun jugement et ça je pense que c'est
ça nous permet de rester en adéquation
avec la réalité du terrain alors vous
avez fait une rencontre très importante
dans votre parcours politique en 2014
votre est tout juste élu maire de Poissy
une rencontre qui s'est faite dans des
circonstances assez étonnantes c'est pas
Elton John que vous avez rencontré mais
c'est directement lié à Elton John
racontez-nous d'abord el c'est un
monstre de de la musique de chanson cinq
fois en concert et il se trouve que
j'étais à Bercy avec avec Claude Claude
Béart et parce que c'est que j'aime la
musique et que avec mon épouse et qui
voyons-nous arriver un jeune ministre de
l'économie qui avait été nommé deux
jours auparavant Emmanuel Macron avec
son épouse et on s'est retrouvé à
chanter à danser sur Elton John avec
avec Madame Macron mon épouse et là
encore moi je me suis pas demandé si
c'était le ministre de l'économie que
j'avais en face de moi et c'est pas
demandé si c'était le jeune maire de
Poissy en revanche on s'est bien marré à
chanter sur voilà sur Elton John sur sur
les Sims to be austral par exemple et
alors ça c'est le début de votre
relation avec le couple Macron avec
Emmanuel Macron vous décririez cette
relation que vous avez avec lui est-ce
que c'est avant tout politique ou est-ce
que c'est une relation d'amitié un peu
des deux oui franchement je crois que le
président Macron est un homme vrai celui
qui met ses actes en face de de ces mots
moi il m'arrive de l'appeler pour
pour lui dire Président vous devriez par
exemple appeler le l'arbitre de la
finale de la Coupe du monde de rugby qui
est une première dans l'histoire d'une
Coupe du Monde arbitrée par un Français
merde je l'ai pas fait trouve-moi son
numéro oui on a des relations
particulières mais tellement simple
pendant la crise des gilets jaunes
Emmanuel Macron vous a fait venir à
l'Élysée avec un petit groupe d'élus
locaux des Yvelines Emmanuel Macron m'a
fait venir l'Élysée j'ai dit au
président la réforme que vous les
réformes que vous voulez mettre en place
les Français les ont bien compris mais
la manière dont vous souhaitez les
mettre en place sont catastrophiques et
je vous propose de que vous veniez nous
voir ici à Poissy pendant deux heures ça
va pas vous plaire mais vous allez en
prendre ça va vous rendre service je lui
dis tu vas en prendre plein la gueule et
il m'a dit banco sauf que c'est le jour
au Puy au Puy-en-Velay où il y a
l'incendie d'une préfecture où ça
s'était très mal passé donc nous sommes
exactement et donc on se retrouve avec
d'autres élus locaux des Yvelines avec
générations et là vous lui avez tenu un
langage assez cash pour lui faire
prendre conscience c'est ça de ce qui se
passait sur le terrain c'était on lui a
dit qu'il fallait absolument venir
sentir le cul des vaches comme on dit en
Bretagne c'est-à-dire descendre
descendre sur le terrain voir comment ça
se passe au sortir de cette réunion
quelques semaines après il y a le grand
débat qui se qui se met en place et on a
une le sentiment que nous avions et je
connais le président encore une fois
entre 2017 et 2019 on était enfin le
sentiment que j'avais c'est que il y
avait une déconnexion totale entre des
décisions qui étaient prises je décide
vous exécuter sur le terrain ce lien
avec le terrain vous y teniez beaucoup
en tant que mère de Poissy mais vous
l'avez perdu en renonçant à votre
écharpe de mer pour devenir député et
tout ça s'était dit évidemment au nom
cumul des mandats et du coup à peine à
peine élu à l'Assemblée vous avez rédigé
une proposition de loi pour essayer de
changer les règles je trouve dommage on
le voit sur le terrain et c'est l'ancien
maire qui vous parle oui il y a
effectivement c'est fantassins de la
République qui sont en prise directe
avec la réalité du terrain qui sont
plébiscitées par les Français qui ne
font plus partie du tout de fait des
deux chambres et la crise démocratique
est là vous avez écouté je sais très
bienveillant il est très bienveillant
alors une majorité de députés étaient
d'accord avec vous Emmanuel Macron
lui-même vous venez de l'expliquer là
sur sur France 2 le problème c'est que
votre proposition de loi elle a été
enterrée par vos collègues de la
majorité est-ce que ça vous a surpris
déçu non c'est le cheminement normal je
pouvais comprendre que les collègues de
la majorité n'avaient pas eu avaient été
élu sur une promesse de non-retours
recumulent la vérité c'est que c'est une
vaste hypocrisie c'est que tout le monde
mon petit doigt me dit Clément Méry que
sa chemine et que dans la réforme des
institutions on va retrouver cela il
suffit d'écouter Stéphane séjourné il y
a quelques semaines c'est important on
est passé encore une fois de de 250
députés dans l'hémicycle en 2012 à zéro
aujourd'hui je crois qu'il y a un juste
milieu
à trouver oui bien sûr à trouver par
rapport par rapport à cela on peut être
on peut être aujourd'hui député
départementale en cumulant les années
limités députés conseil régional en
cumulant des indemnités on pourrait pas
être maire et député sans être par
exemple à l'exécutif c'est une veste
hypocrisie et la France a besoin de cela
la France a besoin d'un souffle de
terrain qui représenté par les mers mais
sur cette expérience un peu ratée on va
dire cette proposition de loi enterrée
est-ce que c'est pas un peu frustrant
vous découvrez la réalité de ce qu'est
un député par rapport à ce que peut être
un maire qui a beaucoup plus de coups de
franges sur son territoire il peut agir
et prendre des décisions seules
on est on est 100% exécutif entre
guillemets c'est PDG c'est pas vraiment
le mot mais et on passe à
auto-entrepreneur ici à l'Assemblée
c'est-à-dire que on a un rôle de
législateur mais il y a pas que ça quand
je propose une loi sur le gaspillage
transpartisane au collègue au collègue
galère et qu'on m'a dit 10 jours après
transpartisanes lutte contre le
gaspillage qui doit faire qui doit
transcender les bancs et on me dit non
parce que c'est la majorité
présidentielle qui présente ça les gars
vous passez votre vie à parler du pays
mais ce qui vous intéresse c'est votre
partie ça suffit c'est l'heure de notre
quiz à présent pour voir un peu quelle
sorte de député vous êtes je vous
explique le principe je vais commencer
une phrase et ça va être à vous de la
compléter c'est bon pour vous on y va
être député c'est comme au foot
c'est toujours tenté même si on ne
réussit pas mais toujours tenter
d'accord je pensais que vous allez
parler de jouer collectif mais non pas
forcément
à chaque fois que je vous vois que je
vois un député sans cravate dans
l'hémicycle ça me donne des boutons
ouais vous aimez pas ça pas sans cravate
mais quelqu'un qui arrive presque en
jean en jean troué à côté des huissiers
des des administrateurs de l'assemblée
qui sont à nul autre pareil toujours je
dirais très élégant c'est pas un
concours d'élégance mais il y a on
représente le respect oui et on
représente la représentation nationale
c'est quelque chose être député de la
nation c'est quelque chose moi je suis
fier de de mon pays on doit l'incarner
au plus haut niveau beaucoup de gens me
voient devenir ministre le problème
c'est que
c'est que c'est pas une science et que
le fruit tombera quand il sera mûr si
les murs et je suis le plus heureux du
monde vous avez toujours eu besoin de
bouger à chaque fois que vous avez
atteint un stade dans votre vie viser un
nouvel objectif ministre ça pourrait
être l'objectif d'après oui enfin c'est
pas une c'est pas une fin en soi et si
on peut juste être utile si vous devenez
ministre un jour est-ce que vous
continuerez à présenter vos vœux comme
ça
pour dans les premiers temps donner la
fou aux habitants le temps de faire
c'est les vœux que vous avez présenté en
tant que député au 1er janvier vous avez
quand même choisi une chanson un peu
triste non pour présenter vos vœux c'est
la chanson des divorcés pour raconter un
peu le passage difficile de maire a
député c'est-à-dire vous êtes malheureux
à l'Assemblée
donc je fais non mais c'était plus
facile avec les divorcés sur ces
allitérations et sévère en huit pieds
sur la Bande à Basile sur la queuleuleu
je ne sais quoi vous êtes heureux la
preuve c'est ce que je dis dans la
chanson mais il faut il faut aussi voilà
mastiquer façonner le fait effectivement
d'avoir eu à gérer un village dans
lequel vous êtes né de 40000 habitants
avec 850 agents et 105 millions de
budget d'euros à effectivement le fait
de devenir député un 577ème de
l'Assemblée mais c'est formidable ça
très très bel engagement merci beaucoup
c'est arrivé un paquet de foire
si on manquait de quoi que ce soit il y
a toujours le 49,3
qu'Elisabeth peut dégainer
[Musique]
on ne veut pas on arrivait là
l'opposition fait tout pour ça et la
Majo toi t'avancer